math is where this Beth is in
Pennsylvania hi Beth how are you good
how are you days better than I deserve
what's up my husband has been at the
same job for 47 years and retired
military about 21 years he got a letter
in the mail Saturday stating that his
position was terminated and they fired
him in the mail after 47 years well due
to the kovat and he understands that
everybody got the same letter so wait so
they closing another they're closing the
company well I'm not sure it's a pretty
big company and there's a lot of like
offices like there's one in Pittsburgh
but there's one so everybody hadn't get
the same letter but a lot of people do
no I don't believe everybody did but a
lot of people did okay yeah Wow and he's
going to be 70 on Thursday and happy
birthday on it yeah happy birthday yeah
he says sarcastically okay so what what
was he doing for a living
um kind of like drove a truck that
delivered parts that broke like four
mines and different facilities who would
pick up the piece that was broke and
take it back and they repair and then
when he was driving a truck and during
delivery basic basically yeah and it
wasn't one of those I've worked in the
company does he want to do that more I
don't think he's quite ready to retire
okay how much was he thinking I work
probably about 60,000 a year so he's got
a CDL well he did but they have been
downsizing and going a little bit
smaller so they he doesn't need a CDL
now so he doesn't have it but he also is
on disability through VA so I was
getting to be you know whether he really
needed it or accrued could do this
yelling and I'm I just found out this
morning he does not have much in the
401k and that was my next question was
what do what do we do with this 401k
it's very little and when we've got debt
and I'm panicked I don't I don't know
what to do how much debt do you have
about 234 on the house and tagged with
three or four payments on a truck then
we have a stupid dummy payment on a
another vehicle in that payments like
860 a month it was eight hundred and
sixty dollars yeah and it won't like
what I want a Toyota 4runner there was
four or five cars turns it into that
regardless of the situation I'm going
quick sidebar on that get that sold
that's gonna Saturday I think it is -
and can I like just get rid of it and
still take a ten or fifteen thousand
dollar loss absolutely or absorb
whatever it is you have to stop the
madness
yes and he is he's drawing Social
Security income on one disability we're
raising his great-grandson who's
autistic so yeah I'm ready to lose my
mind
mm-hmm I can imagine okay well I think
he's going to get gainful employment
immediately it doesn't really have a
choice and and then you guys need to get
a game plan on your overall finances so
that the panic can leave your throat
okay and we'll help you with that I'm
gonna put you on hold and Kelly's gonna
pick up and we'll get you signed up for
Ramsay plus for a year maybe if you want
one year membership to that included in
Ramsey plus right now when people that
sign up for the membership is a fifteen
minute free counseling session with a
coach and they can sit down and help you
unpack the rest of this and help you get
started
you and your husband for his birthday
present are gonna go through Financial
Peace University you're gonna get on the
every dollar sync budget sync up with
the bank and get everything going and
you're gonna do it all where it's gonna
be completely free I'm paying for it
okay thank you so much okay because you
have gotten at it you gotta lay a game
plan out here because it's you're just
terrified and I don't blame you I've
been there I know how it feels
well we're not on the same page I'm a
listener and struggling yeah what you
here's the thing we're gonna sit down
honey in front of this computer and
you're gonna watch this with me and
you're gonna help me get on this budget
or I'm gonna duct-tape you to the
freaking chair until you do when he
wakes up in the morning he will have
been duct-taped to the bed by his wife
until the election system no it costs
about $5 for a whole roll of duct tape
and you you know this is a metaphor
right constructed yeah I can hear this
now but uh yeah you yeah you got it he's
got up he's been working his whole life
and he thought that was enough and it
turns out it's not just getting up and
going to work doesn't do it because you
end up being a rat nut wheel with the
Toyota Sienna with an $800 car payment
and so just working but working a plan
now that'll take you somewhere it's a
different thing so Ken what's he do with
that job well Kelly give give them the
get hired digital course from Ken
Coleman comm we just we just turned that
that's been out about a week and that's
gonna walk him through some basics like
oh yeah it's it's a wonderful little
11:00 part video series after watching
FPE that little it's a big deal
well yeah but the point is is he can get
through it quickly and it's gonna really
help him from everything to I'm gonna
find work to standing out he's got a
great track record as far as a work
career but and you were off the headsets
we gave her one year
Bram's you blush okay yeah yeah yeah so
I want him to get hired quickly and and
here's the deal
he's been driving a truck good news is
those jobs are plentiful right now they
are so it's not like it's not like he's
in a situation where he's like oh how do
I get hired at this point former
military yeah a guy who's held down a
steady job 47 years driving a truck he
steps right into it people understand
covert layoffs this is not some
aberration some so aberrations were all
what crazy in a circumstance so just get
after it I'd be looking for two jobs at
this point because you got a
great-grandchild
on top of everything else he's got to
get after it quickly and I think she
said there was another truck they had
three or four payments on the e to get
rid of that to her those payments yeah
get rid of him and he can get there and
she can - yeah this is doable we'll help
you will walk with you kiddo you can get
through this and you call us back if you
got any more questions